a hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
you're probably gonna burn
do you think I am I mean you know
anything I'm saying that out loud
actually oh there's something I just
mister yeah yeah by tastic pastor demean
your drug dealer
yeah come on pastor use browser for you
room if you mean that my heart's
addicted to the Lord then ya think Jesus
Christ is why don't you I think he was
tan yeah you think I'll go tan I think
[ __ ] like Derek like Derek lark I
don't think dad was black well I don't
know if Jesus dad was black dude first
of all some of the stuff Jesus did the
wine milling around in the desert
definitely kind of black activity so
yeah I'd say back skin it was good these
are [ __ ] actor agreed you make stuff on
the dime carpenter millions and billions
of children had that jheri curl he did
have it actually Jake oh they try to say
escrow right okay really yeah Oh save
your curl yeah yeah yeah what happened
this city woody a sinner's curse and the
ladies around back getting a sip off
that drip Adam and Eve yeah I think
Jesus definitely had us he definitely
had a tan you know ah there's no doubt
if you think he's a blue-eyed white dude
then [ __ ] I think he is sometimes I
don't think so dude no he is if he wants
to be at least on Halloween oh yeah it
was white faith on Halloween no I think
he does everything he wants to do do it
if he wants to black out a little bit he
wants to have a barbecue and you know
meet some people at the park he Urban's
out you know what I'm saying when he
wants to make stuff and like and make
good food he's Mexican yeah maybe gets a
Latino yeah if he wants to get a pistol
you know here's another thing to shoot
at shoot in the air on New Year's Eve
nobody a couple neighborhoods over yeah
you got a luxury no out why not dude
he's anything he might be black cuz he
shredded Easter at City
he's Quito you think he is yeah that's
all they had back then but forgot a
fruit to like two chapters of the Bible
I think he was eating sand bro he was
very then
diet out there if you want to be in a
diet move to the Middle East you know
I'm saying everybody's over your fat and
around all these books carbs and yeah
doing all the next kedo trend yes and
dude I want to go on making afraid just
lose weight sixty days straight I'm so
jealous when they lose weight I wish
someone would force me on on the island
to lose weight naked chick well then
bust nuts and eat bugs give it up what
does real touch you touch me what's
going on an island together oh speaking
of that somebody brought this gift to
the to my show this week Wow no the bus
lamp is it all sticky uh no I don't
think it's been using actual lava lamp
if this is an original line to go in the
in the studio I wouldn't put this up
when this is done but there oh a cat a
call coming in from simon rex an app
right now dirt nice he's in the hospital
you want to say - Oh what happened - I
don't really want to see yeah all right
no servants in hospitals not good thing
good wealthy dirt you want to be on King
in the saying or no yeah this is heaven
dude unfortunately when you
unfortunately yeah you got into the kind
of rough heaven it's just me and bread
is what it looks like you're on laughing
gasps probably relaxing that
you URI men Oh
damn how done have been Planned
Parenthood it's like snow white kinda
like when she bites that Apple well and
that is actually probably a warning that
a lot of Argonaut that a lot of because
we have a lot of young males out there
who I'm sure struggling in the nut if
you got whiteheads on your nuts man be
careful out there
you got a happy on your nuts how would
you do a different Simon to the hospital
[Laughter]
well look my hands are getting trained
brother yes man welcome to heaven well
welcome to heaven man we all love you
and we hope that you feel better fast
brother take care of that Sacro you know
that's bro there's a lot of great people
up here dude
Petros is up here yeah they're not
telling anybody but yeah surprise
Michael Jackson's up here as well my man
oh it's Spacey yeah there's definitely
space he could be here too so but we
love you man I hope you feel better soon
man I'll hit you up later dude
man hope ease hope he makes it out I
mean yeah that's crazy something's in
his nuts anyone to get it it sounds like
yeah anything growing hair on your nuts
that's I've never heard of that well how
do you I guess your nuts are actually
because there's something outside am i
nuts like a skin bag yours too right
yeah like a batwing yeah just like a
coin with like a thing for coins or
something yeah like a leather pouch cuz
nobody has just two nuts hanging there
with nothing around him right no and
then there's like a few fickle hairs on
a banana has hairy nut Oh a lot of
people do not hairy nuts like real beard
where you don't think he probably has a
beard on his nuts also look at Derrick
lark and jr. do you don't think dairy no
no bro that's so true yeah I can't even
imagine man neither can you draw a
picture of it if you gave me two hours
in about sixty markers I couldn't even
draw I don't have the mind for it yeah I
just I came in imagine that it always
clean-shaved in the pornos man what why
are you looking at him in the pornos man
you got a G up brother I am
ladies oh gee you know I look at the
ladies only brother well sometimes you
get that dick in your face you can't do
anything about it yeah you can here's
what I do bro fast-forward just like
that now that you missed the movie dude
huh then you miss the movie yeah but you
know what's going on right you're right
yes enjoy yeah you right though dude how
good is last chance to you though [ __ ]
touch me shout-out to independence that
Coach John Brown the John Brown Jason
Brown Jackson ball and ya gang ROG man
he made outta compton Congrats not the
best coach though is he he's exciting
but I don't know if his his his
motivational techniques are the best way
oh he walks in the room goes what's up
[ __ ]
everyone shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ]
up we gotta win this week every time
that's the truth he's also basically if
you see the team is like everybody has
like nine kids nobody's add that every
other school is let these guys go like
they're yeah they're all rejects from d1
yeah had a Taser on him he was tazed in
the running back nobody can figure out
how he was tackling just so quickly with
just like a quick sound and just his
hand like a quarterback kept bringing a
baseball it deals with some dynamic
today but he figures it out he figures
it up dude some of the kids they're like
all you got to do is go to class today
you get a full ride Alabama yeah paying
two hours later the kids just like I
don't know and then they have these
these poor assistants you have to keep
oh my god dude
it rains out but what season are you on
the newest one I'm on the newest one are
you yeah I'm on it will tell me
everything dude I'm not but coach Brown
is in some trouble no he is and bro he's
a freakin legend dude he's a legend
legends never die dude tell Scotland his
free brother and what about that bus
lamp you got huh yeah up dude she get an
independence community college bus slam
what's up boys yeah suck in that thing
is a full bro first of all how about the
dorms and independence huh can we talk
about the town of independence Kansas
where they used am definitely racist
though yeah
oh my god they do not like the futebol
out there really oh man the stands are
full every game of all the locals kind
of really oh they're not you thinks
everything people are where do you think
people are coming from the watch the
game do you right but it might be the
way team I think most of the time yeah
yeah especially they got the new you're
not updated right I'm obscene two to
three episodes that was a slip during
one episode that town gets a turf field
and they are not happy about it dude cat
looks like Deadpool today huh
what's that mean she's Deadpool color
zone doesn't she
oh okay sorry damn I the only person
that knows about Deadpool no Eric does
well Derek's wearing red and black to
kind of you know but he's got that
Cincinnati this you know the Barry
Larkin bye he's walking around town
don't say anything like barely Larkin
bright he's close but I could see Jesus
having Derek's skin toned Derek Connor
has like kind of that red bone kind of
New Orleans kind of like kind of skin
color yeah that caramel kind of Menace
well dude he was sleeping in a barn and
a couple of the chapters yeah you mean
he had dreads that's what that means
your dreads bro dude black we know if he
comes back I mean when he comes back so
Easter right yeah yeah but definitely
want us her which Easter apparently he
just keeps catfishing he's little and
he's little guy and fat huh he won't be
fat you just told me wouldn't say well
now why we don't know now but what if
he's a little guy and I'm four and a
half feet how's that not a rap name
little Jesus X it is I'm sure bro for
sure
Guu yeah I don't know dude how was San
Fran it's being a lot of Jesus
uh it was good man we had a good time
over there what happened I'm trying to
think it was fast bro it was beautiful
uh fast what do you mean he's just a
quick weekend you were there Friday
Saturday Oh Luke Rockhold came out it
says name Luke Rockhold yeah yeah Luke
rohnke came out great game bit uh and I
asked her about Bisping cuz I guess they
got in a fight one time
and I didn't know that right knocked him
out and that was I didn't know that's
like some kind of do that one time you
bombed being like hey bro how about that
said the improv that night what the [ __ ]
I think you're cool man there no it's
exactly like that I felt but here's the
problem I realize I can't talk to you my
that ever fights because I'm always like
hey I wanted ready to be buddy - Mike
hey aren't you buddies with so they're
like no we're not [ __ ] buddies dude
each other with anybody dude so it was a
fine lost in his eyes of good looking
but he got jet model bro bro ain't you
and I look like turds oh definitely yeah
I don't look that good next to him I
could see you could look Amelie I think
you're kind of answer more than him
you're a little more charming than me is
more of kind of an old-world kind of
like Cologne kind of handsome you know
like dad's Cologne like a Clint Eastwood
type of vibe like if I saw him surfing
on a thing like on a huge ocean full of
like Ralph Lauren Polo Sport that's him
yeah be him liquid that would be him
yeah do people are DM me how good the
show was really does it yeah okay yeah
Mets deal what do you want every Jesus
it felt rough man I'm just
yeah but having so much stress I feel
like I'm losing my mind
bro why so stressed brother I don't know
I don't know I really don't know I think
so it was just in my by himself
huh I feel like you put on yourself yeah
I think some of it is I just got to
tighten up a little bit you know so cuz
it's all good
that's the thing like it's I own it
right so it's Mon beret something in my
own brain ya know I think it's just a
probably good go to somewhere a meaning
get those demons out of your closet yeah
but I don't Ram brother I'm proud of you
man let's do this support man dude I
remember I wouldn't even be able to have
this be here on this show today if I
didn't come on TF 80k you know I mean
that was like the first podcast I really
went on was you guys's yeah and then you
and I had this weird chemistry of just
roasting each other yeah it was like an
anti chemistry really and uh yeah I was
kind of weird abusive relationship back
for more
it was like an episode of snapped kind
of just like starting out or is like a
real bad episode of cheaters yeah and
it's just the same episode over and over
that's being in this thing yeah but yeah
let's get into it man what do we got
today we got Derek and catty here I know
girls Krunk does we're headed to
Nashville this week Memphis baby called
oh wow people coming from your hometown
to see the show oh yeah yeah you have
family 400 tickets yeah how many goes
270 final yeah that's awesome yeah it
could be fun that's all right before we
can start a real quick your boy Nick
sent me something to start the episode
off with because of last week's MC
Hammer surprise Nick sent me this oh
yeah this video is in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
or you're awesome look at the [ __ ]
lamp on the hose and the back bro yeah
your driveway what's up said buzz that's
crazy
crazy dude what's up from this video
about Twitter just when Twitter first
came out man you and your friend wrote
it we make you surrender beer yeah
there's my white friend and his name is
um Alan no not Alan very good friend
though you know Eric how old were you in
that you look yeah beautiful Brunt
look at that [ __ ] arm meat bro yeah
you're pretty you're a little thick
either look I could put my arm straight
up in the air let's deca feel there bro
I was definitely I was definitely a
winstram cycle maybe I never got in a
winstram and I was straight up in that
test I wanted that Mexico running
through my veins bro you want that
Gold's Gym in the mode in the middle of
the night I was on that shoe that we
just had me run to the next country in
the middle of the night I was on this
[ __ ] strong ass Mexican [ __ ] is that
all Cogan come yeah shoot it in and then
just run straight to Canada sometimes
just crazy brother [ __ ] that really they
get up and go dude I was an MC Hammer
video for three milliseconds unis trip
sports take it easy
Sierra's little height boy yeah
Rossi's Flavor Flav look like Bernie
Sanders first someone stole the sleeves
to that shirt actually I left it outside
one night to drive him off and in the
morning the sleeves have been sealed
you must been in the south I don't
remember where I was you know I was
passing through somewhere but dick dear
God man and I needed the sleeves chuck
was out a meeting that next day I didn't
get the gig did oh no I didn't know I
didn't man but well what's up now
Applebee's who's laughing now
God's flying bro yep God that buzz buzz
buzz hilarious I think you Nick and
happy birthday - we got a birthday on
the crew today don't we on a production
crew our boy Daniel yeah
sweet Daniel and uh three Daniel Dee
sweet Dee Dee Dee and it's agent - is he
really adopted Asian wow lks brought low
key Asians man yeah idea around here
anyone else want to come out now and
tell us you Asian you do here due to
Harry to be Asian yep
oh and also Kate yeah I don't think I'm
quite ready to say anything yet oh well
I'm my assumptions crouching cat hidden
dragon from I like it time to pay the
bills well as you can tell I've been in
the gym a little dude you've been in the
gym and I was wondering when you're in
the gym do your shoes just melt
sometimes they can't keep up with that
Theo grind Oh sometimes they just the
heat man that straight up fire coming
out of my feet and just that action the
reaction that's going on inside of me
sometimes I'll just be dead lifting my
shoes go yeah yeah bro I can't have it
so what am I gonna do a little birdie a
jack birdie flew on my shoulder just
cocked up and said get no bull bro yeah
no bull no bull man for the bull that's
actually inside of you no bull doesn't
believe in excuses are BS and that's why
you won't find any in their footwear
apparel accessories wear and tear they
want and welcome we're on it bienvenidos
he wear
they're no bull got you covered don't
let the simple design fool you know
bulls gear is built to perform yet
simple functional designs ground and
performance no gimmicks no excuses
nope no gimmicks no tricks but are we
talking that thickness no bull
they got trainers runners apparel
whatever you need
durable functional training gear visit
noble project comm slash cap yep do
workout do weights do running raise your
children do whatever you want in these
bad boys they're simple they're durable
they're functional visit no bull
project.com / k 80s they take you
straight to shred city that's n OB u ll
p ro je CT comm / tad that's it brennan
spelled it correctly beautiful no bull
project.com / cats brother someone's got
to pay for Brennan's coffee habit what
do you got deep what do we got happy
birthday Daniel we're gonna start with a
little clown my hound up first this is
Dawson from Las Vegas and his dog will
oh god that's a horse
clown my hell not clown my foot and
Clydesdale thing is jacked Wow is that
Luke Rockhold bro what is a he oh wow
look at the puppy is that Dwayne the
rock Johnson splice it looked like
definitely there's been some
crossbreeding going on dude he's so big
I love Great Danes too man but how much
can you love him because I mean look at
the thighs on that thing huh show do you
want a thug can you zoom in on those
[ __ ] thottie Artie's right there
we're being a village you kill that
thing bro oh yeah can't what do you
think about this kind of pup have you
seen these in your area growing they're
not walking around Koreatown nope I have
never seen a dog that big before it's
bigger than me oh yeah oh yeah you could
ride a cat you could ride that thing oh
my god that'd be beautiful
wouldn't it be fun to watch have you
played genuine rabbit my saddle compound
it remember that you ready dude I
remember imagine cat slow-motion oh yeah
in the back what happened to me to break
out a case huh
probably collocation you watch yeah dude
he was super creepy what he's about
sacks of busting nuts on every video
yeah yeah I think he was performing at
the black Expo where we were at really
he was the headliner it's always wet in
every video he's wet yeah I don't trust
them really not around my girl yeah
definitely if you gotta wear some of
that rain X on your decision to say you
know that's rough
uh speaking of rough dude this thing is
what is it I'd eat that
yeah I'd shoot that no doubt if there's
a couple tough months where the power's
out I'd eat the [ __ ] out of that thing
dude dude I feel like you're breaking
the house you had a real problem on your
hand Connor no gun you got some problems
bro you guys can't see this dog I'm not
joking it's standing up it is seven feet
tall
it's tough andre the giant of dogs man
yeah
yeah dude yeah who is it I wonder what
one of his parents is obviously Dennis
Rodman okay here's the thing Brian
sleeps in his bed oh my god bro I hooked
up with this girl in Philadelphia one
time beautiful young lady far as
everybody knows and she had a dog that's
slept in her bed and his name was Kobe
and this was right for Kobe got busted
for the alleged sex and it turned out
yeah and I was like I can't sleep in
here with the dog was way bigger than me
man Kobe yeah I don't trust him they
sleep in the Middle's up in the middle
between us no choice but I was wasted
and I could not even kind of dog was it
you remember that name Kobe oh he was
very great bro I don't know what he was
but he was slightly great I bet you
slept nuts - but - dude he had on socks
I remember
how big he was socks in a nightie just a
hat on he had on socks and I think
evolution on his back glowered he just
smelled good that's the only the only
state of socks Cologne and farmer hole
I'm here gel she might've been [ __ ] in a
row it was a queen bed at best it could
have been a large twin it could have
been a large twin happy birthday
this giant dog doesn't yeah but Dad peer
oh that shit's back who made this it's
this is something that Elon Musk made
after blowing that Johnny Weir [ __ ]
burger you know I must have to make a
[ __ ] that don't work you need mittens
after that we're like oh yeah a floppy
crave oh [ __ ] Elon Musk made after
smoking that joy of next this is Juno
the 13 year old Sphinx cat well that
thing looks like Simon Rex nuts right
now
this front half looks like my grandma's
neck now cat what is this know where you
guys are okay what is it when you guys
see this sort of thing well they have a
much closer relationship with animals
dude than I do what do you mean by they
people different other types of people
from where it from San Jose ciao very
true very true that's fair that's fair
you see I don't know where you're going
with this but that's well no I'm just
saying that cat comes from a more her
historical lineage is a lot more cat
friendly deeper than mine you know so
this could be in Egypt they have a cat
nice magic yes pink sky black magic it's
not black magic do you don't [ __ ]
drag Derek into this okay dude sorry
dear right I'm sorry brown magic well
just magic
well no David Copperfield's magic magic
is white magic right Derek Copperfield
David Copperfield is a closeted male
that's [ __ ] screwing people over out
in Las Vegas bro nice line I mean I mean
taking guys girls and make him disappear
and it was [ __ ] bet yes yeah that guy
sounds like a me-too case waiting to
happen
anyway I shouldn't have asked you cab my
bad I really thought was I
he has losses I do too melanoma having
too much honey dude I'm out bro this
thing looks like a [ __ ] bowling ball
where I'm from dude that loses another
eye bro that thing's gonna be [ __ ]
workin over at Tiffany lanes bro that
thing is gonna be a damn bowling ball
nothin lose another eye it's what
nightmares are made of this thing's
scariest [ __ ] also the owner Persian
what's up with the but look at the
background dude with the [ __ ] the old
statue the marble floor viously persian
look at the [ __ ] cat dude oh you guys
right thousand years old it is lose and
I it's I one of his eyes will settle out
hey man yeah I'm out okay dude this cat
has problems they're pretty nice though
I bet it feels nice too you know your
ball sack feels nice and soft that's
what this cat feels like this cat has
the weight of the world in his soul
broke this thing's been a lot for at
least 2,200 years if you guys can not if
you're not if you're only listening to
this you have to see this cat look at
its one eye and say oh he was kind of
look at his ears huh is there's an eye
hole no that's an ear oh dude I grill
those [ __ ] ears up Boyd oh so no
crying bro Jesus dude could you imagine
the pork rinds off a cat dude I wouldn't
mind lathering him up with a little BB q
sauce Adi bro that's it on the same row
look at that body let's see that [ __ ]
neck bone [ __ ] wrinkled little
wrinkles here o wrinkle in time baby
set my alarm clock yeah I did he looks
like my heel my heels of wrinkly like
that it really adds the senior heels bro
yeah bro I could see you just walking
row you look like a kind of dude that
wear those stockings bro to make your
legs still look kind of tan even talking
about mine B can we zoom in on his
magical orb to the future Derek that I
know what I yes yeah it the thing that
looks like you can see [ __ ] heaven
from air dude look at this Eve the one
evil eye evil this is where our stranger
things dude his eye looks like the
opening and stranger things it does can
i dude oh I bet if you jumped off a
building and landed right in that eye
bro you go directly to heaven dude you
get a desk job there or you go to 1960
dude don't bring this thing around me
I'd have to kill it I don't I don't
trust him
oh I don't trust him I would put this
thing on a very high plateau in my room
I would boil it at night I would make
sure it's covered in cotton and it
sleeps well I'd [ __ ] do it I would
make sure that it is I wouldn't even
walk it I would carry it outside to
urinate in the yard and bring it back in
are you gonna take care of him like he's
a like he's some sort of special gem and
I look at him bro you could [ __ ] keep
cigarettes in one of his eye sockets put
your cigarettes out on this eye socket
if you wouldn't know the difference
I would bro that thing remembers dude
what else he got yes
what's his name oh Jesus Christ two
things you know up next boys we got a
little debate club the big club up first
is Alexander sand of all this is
Alexander hey man do City brah I got to
bake
for you coming to you from kuta bali Sun
gang debate club oh you rich kids in the
Marines we said don't fight in front of
the kids
we had junior Marines come in and we
didn't fight in front of them argue
points because he didn't want your
junior Marines you know your kids in
other words seeing you know one person
being more secure than the other you
want you want the kids seeing the adults
the couple whoever as equals or on the
other hand fight in front of the kids
that's what happens let them see how you
work it out
that's real let me know what you guys
think appreciate what you guys do one
love
buzz buzz dug gang you grew up with your
parents arguing a little bit I don't
know my dad would drink and then go sit
out in his car for a long time um argue
with himself sounds like yeah I don't
know
oh my mom was always yelling at my dad
so I probably made me mad so I think
yeah maybe as a kid you get defensive
for one of your parents kinda you
protect them so you start to maybe hold
a grudge you don't even really realize
against one of them yeah my parent would
got a divorce they would argue like a
[ __ ] really yeah that's why I
like to argue I think listen it's a good
time
they don't argue what are we doing man I
like to mix it up every now and then
I'll just start arguing for no reason
some days oh I can imagine that's just
fun I can imagine that on that's how
lawyers come about man yeah don't don't
let your kid thinks life is easy throw a
debate at his ass every now and then
yeah that's all you do do a crime and
let him [ __ ] defend you in the in the
courtroom yeah but what I'm thinking
this man what was the guy asking are you
in front of kids oh right you can't call
them juniors yeah there's not like
military brats Marine thing yeah yeah
word yeah I think yeah I use them bro
well I think what is he asking us down
there okay to argue in front of kids I
think here's the deal dude if you argue
in front of the kids
then then also you might be having sex
or something afterwards and the kids are
gonna hear that the makeup say you're
gonna learn about sex if your parents
don't argue here's the thing my son
thinks me and my girl argue and then we
in a wrestling match oh really
we ain't wrestling so
in a resin bra yeah but also I can see
who be the kind of guy that puts on a
Lucha Libre master [ __ ] yeah ballsy
popped up and the match is over and mama
has even broke a sweat
hey one way or the other Derek over his
busted nuts with any fights are not
bunch of nuts and his girl bro I'm
surprised he was able to walk out of the
house without slipping and falling a
break in his own back the skeet shot
over holes I can slippery American
drippy Luba freaking drip drop a Potamus
over there what do you think guys
arguing in front of the kids that your
parents argue in front of you Derek and
Kat but my parents I can remember like
only like three or four men they kept it
light they kept it like they didn't
really argue in front of us that shit's
boring yeah okay you cats are happily
married oh yeah my parents fought all
the time but it was more one-sided my
mom would yell at my dad and keep just
kind of laughs oh yeah yeah the women
run [ __ ] am i your mom ever hit your dad
yeah yeah oh yeah my dad just gonna
laugh it off though she's tiny you might
like that
mmm I would watch this what their way of
flirting that turned me on your mom
looks like you even smaller
she's like 411 you seen cats sister huh
seen cats sister yeah that mean my magic
cat with one eye sees the system she is
a baddie Oh is she yeah she only likes
guys that looked like Derek though oh
yeah
and she's an adult yeah she's two years
younger than for her birthday they got a
black guy yeah Wow I thought I was gonna
be the most racist got in this episode
and you just wanted that racist though
but you can't give a black guy as a gift
to someone okay well that's what she
loves
huh well you ask cat when what cat was
actually brought on the show you went
cat how do you feel about this cat it's
in your history that was the most racist
thing so far okay until you drunk me now
you can get someone a blow-up doll and
paint it black that's different that's
racist is that if you viewed a blob
don't put chocolate face on it just get
a black doll bro through the body I
wouldn't do that
nice inverse dude that's what
bodybuilders do I don't support that
well I think if the parents fight though
the kids are gonna see it you gotta give
the kids some problems but also you want
you know want your kid having a smooth
ride that needs to understand
relationships take work dude
that's true I think if you're gonna
fight me guys argue with my girl then
just toss my son to M&Ms yeah it's all
good baby yeah yeah that's pretty good
here's a little chocolate for your boy
huh here's a little chocolate dad won
that debate you know I think that'd be
good maybe you each sit there with some
M&Ms and keep giving them back and forth
to your son till he can't take anymore
whoever gave him the last one wins the
argument not that any bad idea you know
or throw just called chocolate and up
the boy in chocolate the boy now that's
a cute way to win you know you shouldn't
be fighting from the kids though all
honesty really shouldn't it ain't good
do you mean Theo our prints aren't you'd
like [ __ ] but historically how do people
deal with it though historically not
good it can't be good if your kid grows
up in an unsettling environment i ground
like you want your kid to grow up a
little different heels like smooth
sailing but you don't want fighting from
the kid man
well what's fair call my girl crazy and
from my kid now a son starts calling her
crazy oh wow you crazy
yeah no way you're right you speak the
truth right you retinol I appreciate
that yeah yeah this is st. in the garage
you know but she crazy that's wrong what
else we got 85% of people said no
fighting in front of the kiddies as well
up next we got j-rod this is j-rod oh
yeah we don't seen him and I grabbed
yeah
[Music]
guys crazy a great way
oh yeah he's great in the great feel
grades you died and crazy dude
j-rod dick or farting boy oh I think
farts is more enjoyable I think because
the fart is almost like a joke it's like
your butt telling like a little like
one-liner huh you know you hear the one
about them you know and actually in some
cultures they used to try and decipher
the sounds of body gas farts you know
yeah yeah they user meant something you
know a culture of human culture man all
of them dude probably eighty [ __ ]
percent one huh pick one culture human
okay dude dude I'm saying is was it the
Asians with the black hole dude I'm
Hispanic but we're one for one culture
man human culture dude okay you know I
think somebody's trying to decipher a
fart sound
I thought the cranes did it yeah I would
be shocked you're seeing a scat video
huh you've seen scab Bay know what like
somebody telling a cat to let get away
real fast yeah kind of look it up alone
really yeah smoke a cigarette and watch
cat videos get my mom used to always see
it oh yeah it's also a jazz terms gets
gets gets gets get its get it yeah look
it up um I'm a dick joke guy oh yeah I
like dicks better in a weird non home
away I think it digs it's way funnier
you picked the wrong one D what do you
think here dude I think again it goes
extreme man like like dick jokes better
than fart jokes diarrhea jokes about
dick jokes you know I mean I think going
on some all dude really nothing finding
a good big dick joke yeah well digs have
always been a little bit more popular I
think you know because dicks is um
remember these two have those shirts big
Johnson shirts and it was all about dick
you know yeah I think that's the
of those big Johnson know what your
mother slim-jim commercials those are
about dicks to what that's about a snack
dick but you remember big Johnson shirts
you talking about big Johnson the truck
took my big Johnson dog big Johnson big
[ __ ] big Johnson are you talking you
know that's the porno star it's gonna
call big Johnson right there it says
lick suck and you wallow big Johnson bra
huh
there you go Johnson bonzi gentleman
it's his wiener oh I do remember these
shriek Johnson oh great [ __ ]
reference yeah dad
so dicks had their own shirt they never
really had like a fart shirt
yeah like loud Randle or something you
know an attorney I never had like a
shirt for like body gas you know big
Johnson got that such a [ __ ] member
back put out the fire with big Johnson
hoses you know be seeing his own dick
into a fire he's like the couch Patch
dolls but for [ __ ] remember that
there's no Garbage Pail Kids
oh yeah yeah big dick johnson god that's
right that's such an old-school
reference dude so yeah i think that's
the thing that you should know about
having a big dick and i did my research
cuz i was like why am i gonna do with
this thing you so here it is back in the
day in the Greek culture you know if you
had a big dick you're made fun of it's a
bad move so we know all the statues in
Italy all the great men have these tiny
dicks that's not true dude you don't
think now if you had a big dick that
everyone made fun of you I'm sure well
the big dick looks dumb bro you know I'm
saying you run it you know people are
it's more about you know it's what guys
a small dick say really that's what I
heard
dude I'll [ __ ] tie my dick around
your neck right now I'll tie it all the
way around your neck and won't even feel
it stretch dude I rolled over one night
in bed my penis fell out of bed and
broke the back of a full-grown cat here
Lestat that's how that cat
no I don't know man I think but yeah Big
Dig looks dumb as you get older you're
just like this old guy carrying around
this dick and his back is all hurt yeah
I feel bad for those guys yeah
sometimes I'll mmm a portal pop-up and
this dude will have just a monster dick
I'm like what's he gonna do when he gets
older dude yeah it's great dude that
thing's too big well then you got to get
a little like a lunch kit and bring it
you got to carry it in front of your
body limbs got to get a crutch yeah just
hold it up but it yeah are one of those
wheeling crutches like they got in
everybody's a little bit say afraid to
walk their own leg around those guys are
another level man who are they porno
stars dude you never seen like the big
dick porno stars I don't know their
names gonna be so miserable if I had to
[ __ ] twice know their names disease
names dude dingo yeah Rico strong he's
my favorite Wesley Pipes feel good sleep
I saw the most [ __ ] he's always talked
[ __ ] oh wow talk [ __ ] to the girl Jordan
yeah
damn yeah he's like I'm Kanye West or
pornos yeah yeah damn I don't know the
guys yeah I just other dicks do you
think if I if we picked five more stars
and put their dicks in a line if you
could pick them no I bet Derek how many
would you get out of five though one out
of five oh we get none out of five and
Derek how many were four out of five you
know you dicks yeah now here's it can
you girl do the same I don't know she's
watching the porn you watch porno with
you girl yeah we do
oh but not like it's not like at my
office not as much you know not all the
time do y'all watch it like in that
popcorn and stuff like that is it that
kind of thing where you do it at night I
can watch it on the do you watch it you
watching like scheduled viewing or is it
like you don't have like meals around
like watching tonight kind of savage me
I don't know what about cat cats
actually Seymour wieners probably
hopefully the most of us so I don't I
like to watch porn alone I'm not that
fond of watching porn with other people
yeah do you like girl-on-girl
yes oh that does nothing for me I need
it I feel like I'm like watching
girl-on-girl only when the girls are
like drop-dead gorgeous yes just looking
at another
what a beautiful woman is just so much
more appealing to me mmm okay yeah
that'll buy you to be so you like like
you don't like like the butch lesbians
hmm if she's gorgeous
then sure well then she ain't butch if
she's gorgeous cat well she got like
Theo she ain't go home or bowling then
but you know yeah well well
there you go you know yeah and I'm gonna
teach the submission man what an amazing
submission video that cause alleged took
some time yeah straight up legend 75% of
people went with dicks on that yeah you
got it dude we're gonna do a little
relationship advice next do I feel like
we're helping people its relationship
advice if there's one thing I can say
we're helping the world really yep
oh hey you live you right yeah man oh
dude me and my girl got married cuz
you're [ __ ] ganking buzz-buzz Mike
yeah there you go
there you go what do you guys somebody
we just named our kid gang buzz maybe
who helped in the world eh we're
definitely helpful to people that make
birth certificates though laughs a
little what do you got we got Chris from
Montreal Quebec this is great huh
Bienvenue so voice greetings from
Montreal sorry for the lighting needs
some relationship advice you know mo I
took this summer volunteering program at
a residence and asked out my supervisor
on the third week timer now I'm 18 and
she's 21
mmm she said no because it would be
unethical and I know she's pretty
serious about rules I'm still kind of
interested so I was wondering what you
guys think about it do I wait until the
end of the summer and ask her out again
but then I'd be waiting for a month for
a girl I barely know or do I give up and
move on and wait for her to make the
next move since I've already made mine
appreciate it
love you boys no homo buzz buzz game
game buzz buzz Danny seems super
stressed about it here's the things like
Ryan Reynolds it says hilarious that
will run a Deadpool references today Oh
y-you think Ryan Reynolds he like real
renals
oh yeah interesting yeah um you gonna
take offense that listen dude if you
don't want to wait a month
I mean it's not that long brother no
anyway 18 a month seems like years but
if you can't wait a month she ain't
worth it and also yes and technically
it's against the rules well yeah man
that's your boss can't [ __ ] your boss on
summer break dude yeah so wait a month
see what's up yeah man she's worth it
you know I'm saying yeah first of all
you're waiting a month we like wait a
month she already said no so you're just
waiting like that much of a debate she
kind of said no so I think maybe I think
yeah you could after our way to the end
I wouldn't make her feel uncomfortable
be standing around what flowers are like
a little candy thing or something or one
of those [ __ ] things you get where
you get the fruit cut in the flowers and
they send it with the cones in there
trusting their cousin pineapple you the
[ __ ] kid to the sky also keep your
peepers off her - man don't make her
feel uncomfortable yeah bro you know I
would wear glasses in class if you have
to or sunglasses or dark glasses mm-hm
even do a disguise or something you
don't say you just want to make her feel
as comfortable as possible so if she
doesn't think it's you staring at her
then that might be good so if you do
like a little light disguise or like a
different type of bigger shirt it's a
good idea wonder where I had every now
and then yeah do like a big hat like a
kind of a outdoor kind of hat or like a
Nordic if she see if she really cares
about you pretend you're sick and miss
multiple weeks see if she calls you
she's not gonna call dude she's she's
not into it
well we gotta waste our time cuz she
kinda was like I'm not in Tony's like
should I wait a month
I wouldn't I'd move on yeah just don't
move on outside of her door dude you
know just keep it chill I would I would
wait till classes over and then maybe
send a little message or something and
just but just be appropriate about it
and just say hey look uh you know I I
think we should I'm still interested if
you are and then just see what a
response is dude this what I'd do I'd
made I'd make a mix tape on her ass yeah
who's who's doing that these days drop
her a nice little mixtape but a little
genuine on there
yeah a little Jake granny sadly but make
a mixtape with just that song on it ten
times in a row so she really gets the
message
yeah dude that's a great idea or do a
heart of or draw art of her you have you
can draw otherwise it's gonna scare it's
gonna scare either way man and but hey
was brave e to shoot your shot man you
know she's the teacher and he took a
shot at the teacher a lot of young guys
are afraid to do that a lot of half your
class is probably sitting around jerking
off at night to her and at least you
tried to man up you know yeah take some
balls to do that but maybe move on huh
what else you got up next we got a
little punk my uncle boys little punk my
uncle this first one is from Derrick
syntek all right decent that's Steve
Spurrier
[Music]
which one we looking at one standing up
[Music]
summit some white people enjoying a
beverage
everything is whiter than a cake
obviously football draft way too early
in the season okay
started barely got Patrick Mahone and
just freed out he also looks like the
owner of the Raiders bring up the over
there in about a this is dead no it's a
son with that [ __ ] [ __ ] haircut
how you be are you being a billionaire
without [ __ ] haircut and the best way
to be a billionaire I can have a bowl
cut and have a billion dollars in the
bank oh the guy has Down syndrome you
would think but he doesn't he doesn't
purpose so you feel bad for me hedging I
don't think so dude look at the pitcher
do you think I know it's confusing right
billion dollars hell yeah I love that I
bet he cuts his own hair and I [ __ ]
crazy nobody pays a lot of money have
someone get the bowl out and cut his
hair
that's a toupee do that so if it's a
bowl it's a [ __ ] baby hello dear I
mean a helmet yeah I didn't football
helmet what was it was 1940 what was
this guy's question
oh sorry uncle falling oh yeah yeah look
like Pat Summitt are we sure that wasn't
Pat so because I don't you quit coaching
oh you know what she passed me passed
away she did you know cancer got her oh
really oh wow I didn't know that she was
smoked right good coach though yeah she
was one of the best dude and look at
that but very nice and see very similar
very similar haircut see I thought it
was the owner of the Raiders but I was
wrong we're both wrong I think again it
looks like maybe it was a behind the
scenes of the clansmen movie
something I don't know what's going yeah
obviously your uncle got Patrick
Mahone's I think you called it right
Brennan way too early fantasy football
draft at a and either an Applebee's or
an Arby's that also has a bar in it yeah
two guys went there went nuts he could
handle the Todd Gurley slip to the
seventh day dude and he got bod
squirrely bro and he couldn't even
[ __ ] take a step forward it's like
his brain was like hey take a step or
two both of his feet were like nah
[ __ ] face we got Troy oh yeah and T
Roy actually is a correct way to spell
it oh he looks a little bit like my
mother
to Roy this poor guy actually let's hit
this vide man Wow
Troy I mean maybe I shouldn't have loved
you
I don't know brought as often as I could
have is this calm my hound
is that a hound dog
is that a old-country hound dog with a
hat on how much what I wonder is how
much gold is under that do you how many
gold nuggets Ernie that guy's hat did
the San Francisco 49ers name their
football team pickaxes it is true he
looks like he didn't make the cut for
the movie tombstone and just [ __ ]
drank his life which is crazy there's a
handsome dude Oh a beautiful young man
and he has uh it definitely seems like
he's falling some troubled times though
didn't he he looks like you got a guy
likes pumping gas though you know what
I'm saying he likes putting gas into the
car he looks like you just found out his
cat lost to not raise god brother what
else we got
alright boys we handed
a little king of the sting it you know
that videos [ __ ] class first we got
our boy a little bone Jones everybody
LBJ bone Jones hey Theo hey Brennan the
Sebastian on a Garland Texas and I got a
king at her sting okay brother
guys with nipple piercings mmm Gang Gang
buzz buzz well look here's you gotta get
him treated though don't get the
untreated ones cuz they rust and that's
what I've seen
yeah you don't go cheap with the nipple
piercings but also don't do it you don't
do MTV Spring Break 1997 we can't do
that dude you can't get [ __ ] tattoos
and you can't get nipple piercings you
also really can't have a long hair like
that anymore you know
and why is it so wet this is here so wet
dude he probably just got baptized or
something this guy looks like a quality
young fellow it's like a patriot though
I'll give him that
Oh aim small miss small man this dude
would get it done against the Brits okay
I'll tell you that in the heart yeah
there's a problem you ain't lying
bro I'll he'll put those he'll put the
Queen in a casket if he had to you know
what I'm saying this guy could get it
done bro it Winston Churchill got
nothing on this little bad the only time
I like piercings is if I'm at a strip
club some girl some big old today's
really in one spares interesting cuz you
look like the kind of guy that would
have your nipples pierced
really I feel like you would know after
that rap video I like you and your bro
get your nipples pierced and spend all
your money on [ __ ] chicken wings at
yeah but I'll say this get the pre
treated ones if you do get that pre
treated you know you don't want the ones
that that will rust man huh I'm aroused
out of Lake not too long ago in Oklahoma
and they had a guy out there and he had
one of his nipple rings was rusted I was
like man that's could be vintage you got
to get the treatment on it on that steel
I did I just I don't see the benefits to
a do unless you're the Sun hits it when
you got your chest out in the Sun mmm
that could be cool like a wolf look from
the far away what was that oh I kinda
just I don't see the benefits man yeah
yeah I feel like you
like a [ __ ] you did says have
you had your nipple pierced no never
never
what if you have that nose pierced my
ears a couple times no not piercing my
nose dude cuz other bulls will come from
what I pierced my ears probably five or
six times and I was a child you know I
might appears all pierced something I
had like a growth on my hip I think we
pierced it one night pierced I'm all cat
you just your ears are pierced have you
had anything else nope I am not fond of
piercings I like tattoos those are the
only type of needles I can do Jim Lee
tattoos yeah you do yeah okay we went
over this I got one on my side and then
I'm getting another one in November what
are you getting November on my arm yeah
you didn't sleep DUP just my forearm I
feel like you look sexy a little nose
piercing just a little ring I thought
about it I'm I bet you look cool does
your sister have one
no Hillary up just tattoos that
surprises me that's surprising yeah well
uh I'm against nipple piercing were you
on nipple piercing I'm out it seems like
a hassle bro like TSA security you have
to take out your [ __ ] nipples with
your shoes yeah somebody will steal them
to it security they steal [ __ ] plus your
girl dimension girls are slick in your
nipple it's Paris my sexy dude I think
it's brave though I think the dude look
man this guy obviously likes to [ __ ] I
think that this guy [ __ ] outdoors and I
respect that
go put on some [ __ ] he looks like you
put on some Bruce Springsteen and [ __ ]
your brains our King
alright boys last one this is from
Daniel gray go big Daniel big t Dan
what's up dawg got them guns out I don't
know is a gun show
oh speaking of debate looks like there a
debate he wants to eat that [ __ ] she's
like I don't think so
well if you go down on a girl who's
pregnant can you get stem cells like
that mmm that's a good question
look I done my research yeah well I'll
say this man I mean now's a good time
for you to do it one and B this guy
definitely seemed if he's had some stem
cells injected straight into his
shoulders and arms man this guy yes his
wife is pregnant he also may have twins
in his [ __ ] in his arms this guy is
humongous this guy is a little Jack
O'Lantern man yeah dudes a little too
small for my liking
even if tattoos are stretched to the max
you say wolud osius man I think this
dude I think stem cells yeah get a
couple you know you know I wouldn't pick
up anything from the gas station you
know like for our stem cells or tell my
dad John Jones mix yeah I get that
[ __ ] I get something real not
something that was whipped up in a
kitchen you know like John Jones gets
his [ __ ] from [ __ ] you know it seemed
like from Papa John's or something and
then get busted freaks out oh it's
pulsing yeah you got to get the real
stuff uh yeah apparently just injected
straight into his goddamn arms I don't
know dude I don't I wouldn't [ __ ] with
it knows about that but if it makes
everything grow like what if you took
and made your nose grow bigger
you don't saying we don't need that well
maybe we do man imagine if I could was
the ultimate smell champion they know
suck up all the oxygen I do that and
suddenly you can't even breathe anymore
sound you take a deep breath I pass
what a great superpower wouldn't that be
oh you guys didn't believe me huh
you all shut down and go to sleep
pretty dope superpower wouldn't it then
I steal everybody's [ __ ] yeah I take a
little Daniels [ __ ] ID and put a
different his birth certificate and put
a different date on it so he wakes up
and thinks it's still his birthday it
was like weird guy no I change
everything anything that could happen
I'll take this nipple piercings out of
you Brendan have them dude yeah sure you
don't dude let me put this little metal
detector by you okay
the weirdest piercing for guys obviously
bellybutton can't do that a nipple
piercing little strange you're seeing a
like what they called the prints of
what's the prints the piercing you don't
talk about
oh that Prince Albert yeah got Prince
Albert in a can let him out that means
your wieners got a hook in it yeah but
I'll say this dude the craziest piercing
ever Jesus Christ dude they pierced that
dude right up against the fence
it was super goth way it was super
gossamer golf at the time and that's the
pearson really that matters most bro you
know if Jesus took a couple bro you
could take a couple you little [ __ ]
myself I'm not talking to you man no I
feel you man we should all be taking
piercings if Jesus did it that's what
I'm saying bro put [ __ ] one in each
palm dawg use your palms see what's up
yeah what are they gonna say at the
airport they're not gonna let me on the
plane cuz I'm Christian brother who I
will start a real fire on Twitter after
that I'm gonna say no to stem cells
really I don't know enough about him I
would say I think I might be going to
Vegas in about 11 days to get some
injected into my backs yeah find them in
a wheelchair Lisa we proved that I made
some poor choices dude
[Applause]
that's my boy that's your dog that's it
ah I was a quick one man was a quick one
man it was good though
good to be back in here dog yeah good to
be back in your man good to see you do
you brother couple fire episodes
recently huh yeah it was fun man that
last one made me laugh so much so funny
buzz-buzz Gang Gang you're off to get
the car dude yeah take it uber huh yeah
I'm just a little sick of it where I
want to have the options I feel like
uber sick of you I could say feel like
you jump in the front seat it's time to
do that jump to the front seat you get a
lot of the same drivers really yeah
they're like yo what's up dude going
back to yeah forgot to tip me last time
dude forget you just go you just you
know yeah and but it reminds you cuz you
can't move on till you tip them yeah
well it says no tip this one King in the
same fan is out that some guys the guys
will pick me up in like no way that's
cool man so you decide you look good
Brendan really liking a my car man I
just will say he's cool he said man he's
really a real legend thing yeah you know
I had some dude I got my coffee goes all
with the same high school Steve I went
you're lying he didn't go to high school
bro
hahaha laughing oh yeah you went to
where was first period in his living
room yeah some guys like hey I'm Brendan
son okay here's a dress go hit him of
the dudes definitely making child so
bored now so go hit him up for it well
go get that car man we'll get you out of
here yeah man abhi brother I'll be in I
come in Oz I'm gonna be in some Europe
date Stockholm and Norway so that is in
September
yeah in September those are available
Theo von comm slashed or damn you doing
these traveling mister world mr.
worldwide yeah mr. worldwide it's gonna
be fun why were you gonna be I'm in
Nashville this week Thursday Friday
Saturday with Derrick post nd post and a
little little dangerous Brown dangerous
Mouse Isana no man get your guns and
then I'm in Portland after
that and then Houston get your tickets t
pack a calm good to see your brother you
go get a ride man gang or us me don't
touch me do but keep touching me
[Music]